It is twelve 01:00 p.m. On Wednesday,
May 11,
I call this meeting to order and would like to welcome all council members
in attendance. Council Member Amy Peck, council Member Tasha
Jackson, council Member Mary NAN Huffman,
vice Chair Edward J. Pollard, vice Mayor
Pro TEM Martha Castex Tatum, council Member Leticia
Plummer and Council Member Sally Alcorn,
and staff from Council Member Carlos Cisnero's office.
And we missing Tiffany D.
Thomas. Council member Tiffany D Thomas.
Never miss you ever else. We'll hear
about it for the rest of our lives.
Before we start, vice Chair Ed Pollard. As we begin this journey,
this is the first of I think we have 25 meetings,
23 individual departments, and then this
analysis that we'll see this morning on the five year forecast. Any comments?
No comments at this time. Immediately following the
specially called BFA to go over the 2023 budget
workshop, it will begin with the Finance Department presenting at
01:00 today in the Houston Fire Department presenting at 130.
Additionally, the budget workshop schedule is posted on the BFA
website. All budget workshops will be in person except
for public speakers which have the option to comment in person or
virtually. Are there any members of the public who are
here in person and would like to participate? There is a sign up sheet in
the front table. My staff member Carolina will be monitoring
the public speakers list. As a reminder, the only people attending
public or public speak virtually are public speakers. There are
five virtual public speakers signed up for the public comment
for this particular meeting. We will get their questions after
the presentations and after questions from council members have
concluded. At this time, I'd like to welcome Director Tantry Emo
to provide the fiscal year 2023 budget overview
and General Fund five year forecast.
Also like to welcome Council Member David Robinson to the podium
to the Horseshoe, and Deputy Finance
Chair Will The Thrill Jones.
Looking good, Will. And Council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you.
Thank. Good afternoon, mayor protem and council member.
I don't know if you have the slides on. I am
here joined by William, deputy Director William Jones.
He is over the financial Planning and Analysis divisions presenting
the fiscal year 2023 budget overview and General Fund five
year forecast. First, I do want to recognize Mr.
Jones and his limited team members. Hopefully they are all here
who are here today as well as Citywide Department's financial
team for pushing hard to prepare this budget on time. In front of
us. Again, thank you. We do have very limited resources
and I am so proud and pleased so that we can actually
get this budget done timely with that. Let's go
to the slides.
Thank you. So again,
in here we will go over the budget overview and the budget revenues and
expenditures for the General fund as well as the five year forecast.
And we will also go over some updates on the outcome
based budgeting. Next slide.
Again, this is a forward looking statement so that everybody's aware
this is still based on the projections. Any changes in the futures will impact our
numbers. This is again the five year forecast based on our assumptions
that we can derive today. Next Slides
let's start with the citywide expenditures,
including debt service and pay as you go in this slide.
As you see, the fiscal year 23 proposed budget for all funds,
including debt service and pay as you go is at $5.7
billion. This is about $487,000,000
higher than fiscal year 22 current budget at 5.2
billion. This is an increase of 9.31%.
Again, keep in mind this citywide expenditures
includes total budget, includes general funds, special and enterprise funds.
This does not include the surface chargeback funds,
the enterprise funds, as you see in this slide, the enterprise funds accounts
for about 364,000,000 of that $487,000,000
increase. If you see in here, the water and sewer had increased
from 1.3 billion to 1.6 billion alone,
and that is related to the consent decree and other drinking water projects.
In fiscal year 23, General Fund alone accounts for about
48% of the city total funds. And as you
see in here, there's a slight decrease from fiscal year 22
to reflect the total compositions of the funds from 51%
to 48%. Again, because of the increased allocations on the
combined utility system on the General Fund, it increased
by 101,000,000, or about 3.85%
increase, which we will go through more details later on next slide.
Again, this is the citywide full time equivalent for
civilians and classified. As you
see in here, the total FTEs we have for fiscal year 23
is at 21,000, a slight
decrease from fiscal year 22 current budget.
Again, as mentioned by the Mayor yesterday, the fiscal
year 23 proposed includes cadet classes for police and
fire for five classes each. While in fiscal
year 22 current budget, it includes six cadet classes for police
and four cadet classes for fire. Another important notes
to put in the fiscal year 23 proposed budget. In here. The general fund
includes temporary employees for the Higher Houston Youth Program. So you
will see some of those numbers incorporated in the General Fund FTEs.
Next slide.
Again, this is another deep dive of the General Fund compositions
from the civilian and classified from fiscal
year 15 to fiscal year 23.
Again, another thing to point in here, keep in mind the fiscal year
2020 and fiscal year 21 FTEs seems
to be lower. Again, this is due to the redeployment that
was funded out of CRF at that time.
Next slide.
So this is the American rescue plan act. As you all know, this fiscal
year 23 proposed budget also includes funding from the ARPA,
similar to what we did last year. Again, this is just a
reminder. ARPA was signed into law March 11,
2021, providing 65.1
billion federal funding. Our portion for the City of Houston is about
$607.8 million in two tranches. So we
received the first tranche last year around May of $303,000,000.
So we will be expecting the second tranche sometime this month.
Hopefully we have not yet received it. It is typically stated
to be twelve months after the first tranche. The city would
have until December 31, 2024 to use
the fund. Again. Unlike CRF,
ARPA recognizes the economic impact due to the COVID-19 pandemic
and provides flexibility to address reductions in revenues
due to the COVID-19 Public health emergency. The Coronavirus
State and Local Fiscal Recovery Fund final rule was available by
the US. Treasury. Released on January 2022.
So this budget includes 160.1 million
in the ARPA utilization for the provisions of the government services
relative to the revenue reductions due to COVID-19 public
health emergency. Next slide.
Okay, so a quick overview of the General
Fund that we are proposing today. This budget
includes 13.5% fund balance of the expenditures, less debt
service and pay as you go, which is above the desired minimum
of 7.5%, and that is about $138,000,000
above the 7.5%. This budget includes
3% pay raises for the municipal employees,
6% pay raises for the firefighters and 4%
pay raises for the police. Classified this proposed
budget fully fund the budget stabilization fund. So right now we are over
$20 million set aside for the Budget Stabilization Fund.
Again, as mentioned, this funds for cadet classes, five cadet
classes each in police and fire, and also fully
fund all three pension systems. So this budget does not include fund
balance drawdown, nor one time land sales, nor payment deferrals.
So let's start with the General Fund revenues.
So this is the net change of the General Fund revenues including
other sources. So that includes sale of land and transfers.
Compared to the fiscal year 22 estimates, the proposed budget
increased by about 2.4%. So our 2.7
million compared to the fiscal year 22 estimates of 2.67
million. Let's start with the biggest increase which
is from the bottom, which is property tax,
$48.8 million increase. And again,
this is based on Proposition One and
H limitations that we have, which is based on the populations plus
CPI. Keep in mind the CPI is already available at this
point at 4.8%.
The population is still at 0% assumptions waiting
until the US census Bureau released it sometimes in
May. Intergovernmental this has increased by
10.4 million compared to fiscal year 22 estimates.
Again, this is where you see the use of
the ARPA funding, which is 160,000,000 compared
to fiscal year 22. We use about 139 million.
So roughly those are increases in the intergovernmental.
We also reflect transfer from other funds increased by 3.8
million. This is mainly from the Park Houston funds.
As economies start going back to normal,
so you will see some of those parking fees generated
and so the transfers start coming to increase in fiscal
year 23 charges for services,
this is increased due to higher than anticipated digital network and
network notes. We also have others that
is noted in here. This is because of the interest you see all those
low interest in last year. But now with
the increased cash that we have, we are projecting an increased
interest in our fiscal year 23.
Another decrease in here I'm going to go through the decreases is the
franchise fees. This is again mainly on the telephone franchise that
continues to decline. Next slide.
Again, this is just a composition allocations in the general fund
revenue categories between fiscal year 23 proposed and
fiscal year 22 estimates. Again the biggest
chunk that we have in our revenue sources are two.
Property tax and sales tax continue to be our
primary sources that compose about 67
70% of the general fund.
We also have the other funds and franchise fees as noted in here. Again,
keep in mind this revenues includes the funding from ARPA of
160,000,000 in the intergovernmental.
Next slide.
Again, this is just another different look on a
bar chart and you could see the comparison
from fiscal year 15 all the way to fiscal year 23
proposed budget for the property tax, sales tax, franchise and
other revenues. You could see some
of those dip in fiscal year 2020 and
21 slight movement because again because of
the COVID Next slide
on the property tax revenues. Again this
is based on the estimated taxable value of $289,000,000,000,
which is an increase of 8.98%.
This estimated taxable value is the net off the tax
incremental agreements which is 246.2 billion.
Again, population data from the US Census Bureau as of July 1
has yet to be received. So our property tax
revenues in here is only based on the CPI index
of 4.3%. I misspoke, I said 4.8 is 4.28%
initially and we will adjust this calculations once
the US Census Bureau data is available by the end of May.
So with that the increased property tax revenues is at 3.97%,
which is 48.9 million higher than fiscal year
22 estimates. Again, this is still based
on the over 65 and disabled exemptions at 160,000
and I know Mayor had mentioned yesterday that he proposed
to increase that over 65 and disabled exemptions from
160,000 to 260,000 in a separate
council actions, sometimes in June.
Next slide again,
so this is based on the budget versus
actual of the property tax revenues from fiscal year 19
to fiscal year 23. Again, the adopted
budget since fiscal year 15 is based on the proposition
one plus H and you could see the delta between
those with the actual. So fiscal year 22 estimates
right now is not projected to be changing,
so we are still remaining our projections at the revenue
cap and again fiscal year 23 proposed
budget is also at the revenue cap.
Next slide.
And you've seen this before, this is just a chart
to show the impact of the charter cap to
what we have at this time since fiscal year
17. So again since fiscal year 19 we already hit
the property revenue cap where we were based
on the populations plus CPI growth
in our revenues. But if we did not have that
so you could see in here the impact of that is about 1.4
billion from fiscal year 15. The impact of
the prop the revenue cap we have for fiscal year 23
as you see in there is at $282,000,000.
Next slide. Thank you.
Moving on to the sales tax revenues. Again,
we are conservative as we are heading into fiscal year 23
budget. So we keep our percentage growth for
sales tax flat.
This estimate reflect an improvement to the economic conditions compared to
fiscal year 2021 which was severely impacted by COVID-19
Pandemic which affected our national and global
economy. So although the energy sector has
contributed significantly to the Houston economy, the ongoing volatility
of the Russian's invasions of Ukraine has caused uncertainties
among the oil industry. So current average oil price
is at 109.77 per barrel. This is
as of May 6. So therefore the proposed budget assumes
no growth from the fiscal year 22 estimates.
And when we look at Dr. Gilmer which
is our consultants on the sales tax and the economists who's
from the Institute for Regional Forecasting at the UFH,
he projected the fiscal year 23 range for the city sales tax
ranging from the low of 773 to 812,000,000.
So we are somewhat in the middle at this point. Again,
it's a lot of moving factors
going forward. So we want to be conservative and just we leave it as flat
at this point from fiscal year 22 estimates we had seen, of course,
as you all see it every single month are projecting increasing in the sales tax
as we receive more receipts in this year.
But again, we don't know what we don't know. So we want to leave it
flat at this time. Next slide.
Okay, so this is the trends on the sales tax. Again, sales tax
is very volatile. It changes
very quickly as the economy shifted.
You see what happened with the Pandemic. So with the drop in
state home, so that revenues which would decrease
tremendously. So again comparison from
fiscal year 19 where we are at with
our sales tax.
So now we're moving on to the John Fund expenditures.
So again, this is the net change from fiscal year 20
to current budget. So we are reflecting about 3.85%
increase in the general fund of 2.7 billion compared to
the 2.6 billion major changes
we have in there is on the operating budget.
Again, it includes the employee compensations. So that is
an increase of 44.6 million. So that is on the fire,
police and municipal pay raises also have the
surface chargeback funds. This is restricted accounts of 18.35
million health benefits includes about 14.7
million increases in here other surface
chargeback and I know we put that note in there is for the contract
escalations and new facility operating cost we
also project some savings in this proposed
budget, mainly on the pension. So you see
the pension and note four showing a reduction of
2.3 million. This is because of the rate changes from the midpoint
to the minimum point for the fire pension as they are falling
below the minimum corridor at this point.
And also deferral. If you recall our
budget in fiscal year 2000 and 22,021 includes
deferral for the Walker lease building.
So now we don't have deferral anymore. So we only pay what
we are owed on an annual basis. So that shows some saving
on the debt service and payers to go, it increased by 22.6
million. Again, some of that is pertaining to the captured
revenues pay go as increase in the CPIs included
in that calculation as well and also
transfer of the debt service. Now this does not include any
prepayment from the building inspections. If you recall our previous
budget includes debt prepayment for the building inspection funds.
So this is not including that. So you will see some of those uptick
because of no longer debt prepayment from the building inspections included
in this debt service transfers.
Next slide. Okay,
again, this is just a comparison of the allocated
general fund expenditures including debt service from fiscal year 23 to fiscal
year 22. Again, public safety still remains the bulk
of the compositions in the general fund.
Police and fire alone is at $1.55 billion.
So compared to this $2.7 billion proposed budget,
police and fire alone includes about 56.4% of the
total budget. Another one that I want to point
out in here is the debt service or the debt service which
is pledged with the property tax revenues
that we have is about 13% of our
general fund budget. 3% is the pay as you
go and you see the remaining is those other departments
including Solid Waste. I think Solid Waste is in one of those other departments.
Next slides.
So this is the compositions of the personnel versus non personnel.
Now overall again our general fund,
62% is personnel, I know we kind of mentioned that earlier,
62% is personnel, 38% is in others.
Out of that 62 personnel, 76 of that
is classified police and fire. Only 24%
is civilians. Again, going back to the others
portion of the 38% debt service
is about 42%. You have the energy costs in there and
other service and chargeback.
Next slide.
So this is a slide just to go through the general fund pension contributions.
I know Mayor had mentioned the pension reform was
done in 2017. So from the unfunded liability point of
view, the pension reform in 2017 reduced the projected unfunded
liability from 8.2 billion to 1.5 billion.
That is reduction about 6.7 billion from the liability
point of view. But what you see in here in this chart is
the projected city pension contributions without
the reform. So if you look at this, the shaded area
in there without the reform we would have had to set
aside another 1.4 billion on the operating funds
to pay for those city contributions.
Again, the full impact from stiscalyte
18 on the city general fund contribution is
about 1.4 billion, if not because of the
pension reform. Next slide
so finally, this is the general fund unassigned ending fund balance.
So as mentioned, so we are now at 13.46%
13.5%. We are at 310.7
million fund balance. So that is about $138,000,000
above the 7.5%. But one thing I do want to note
in here, the fiscal year 22 and
the fiscal year 23 fund balance in here includes ARPA
funding that is not recurring.
So I cannot stress enough on the important to preserve
fund balance because of what's coming ahead in fiscal year 25.
Another thing to put in here, fiscal year 18 amount requires 7.5%.
Fund balance is adjusted to exclude the 910,000,000
pension obligation bond. This is back in fiscal year 18.
Next slide.
So now we're moving to the general fund five year forecast.
Again, this is a forecast which has some assumptions
in the next five years at this point,
but hopefully it would give some ideas of where we're going
to be in the next five years. Again, this projected
gap range based on the conservative and
optimistic growth in revenues, it does not include any
one time land sales for our revenues
property tax revenues. It is in compliance with Propositions One and
Eight limitations holding. The senior disabled exemptions at 160,000 and
the pension assumption is based on and this is to be corrected
based on either minimum or midpoint of the
corridor because of the conditions of those pension groups
on the expenditures. Also includes legal mandates,
staffing for new facilities and contractual escalators starting
with the revenues. Next slide.
So I've talked about what is in the assumptions for the
fiscal year 23 proposed budget. So roughly,
property tax growth is about 4%. Again, the driver of
that is the CPI is the CPI growth rate.
We have not including any populations growth rate. So this is
still based on the 0% populations which will be updated
once we have this data by the end of May. Again,
sales tax growth rates in fiscal year 23 remain
flat. Franchise fees overall its
reduction of 1.2%. Again, bulk of that is the telephone
franchise fees that continues to decline. We also have other
revenue growth at 3.7%. This is on the
Industrial Assessment license and permits as we have seen some
revenue increases in fiscal year 22 as the economy started to pick up
and no one time land sales in here. So you
see the projection from fiscal year 24 to 27,
which is based on the low and the high for our assumptions.
Next slide.
On the expenditure side, again, we've gone through the fiscal
year 23 assumptions.
Police is based on a 4% increase,
fire is based on a 6% increase, pay raises,
municipal Employees is based on a 3% increase
and we've gone through the pension contributions for
fiscal year 23 which is known at this point, is at
the 8.44 for Hmaps which is based on the midpoint.
Again, we also have the legacy pension that
we have to pay to Hmaps at 142,000,000.
H Pops is based on
31.98, which is the midpoint at this point,
and the Fire pension at 26.89 which
is at the minimum point of the corridor.
We have the growth assumption for health benefits at 4%,
which is known at this point. And again the debt service and pays you
go as described earlier. Now going to fiscal
year 24 to 27, this is our assumptions going forward.
We know what has already been in the meet and
confer with police which is 3% 24 and
3.5% 25. So we're not using
any assumptions in the future at this point, which is at TBD.
At this point Fire is 6% in 24 and
TBD. So we just remain at that point for these assumptions
and another 3% in 24 for municipal
employees. Again, H maps for
24 to 27 is based on the midpoint of corridor.
Police and Fire is going to be looking at the minimum.
So we have a range of minimum and midpoint because
they are getting close to the minimum corridor. So we are making some
assumptions at this point because it's still a moving number. So we're making this range
for police and Fire again on the health
benefits because it's still assumptions going forward. We also do a
range on the growth for the health benefits
five to 7% and the debt service of
course is based on our debt service models which is planned payment
for the next five years. So with that
we go to the next slide so we could map this out and
take a look at what the gap
is going to look like. Next slide, please.
So this is roughly what we're looking at in the next five years.
Keep in mind this does not include ARPA funding
so I don't want to skew our visibility
with mixing the ARPA funding in these discussions. As you see
in fiscal year 23 you have about $160,000,000 gap
so that's what ARPA funding came in and fiscal
year 24 does not include ARPA fundings in this scenario
as well. So that is something that we will be incorporating in
next fiscal year and going forward you
have an idea what our range of
gap looks like. Again, this is not using any utilizations
of ARPA funding. Next slide.
So let's take a look back and
see what have we done as a city. I know you've
all seen the PFM studies and so I
do want to put forth what has been done
to see where we are at today because if this is not done then we
would have been in a much worse situations at this point.
So one thing's first of course is the pension reform that was done 2017.
You saw what the impact if that was not done
in that city contributions and unfunded liabilities,
OPAP reform. So we had seen some reductions in the unfunded
liabilities. Shared services we have
done on the joint processing center. We have shared services with
the Harris County, of course, continuing hiring control
through the Mayor staffing Efficiencies program.
You've seen all the claw back provisions
that we had implemented a couple of years ago.
You've seen the EMSC adjustments that went to council
several years ago as well. And of course the health
benefits update, negotiated Cdwat medical and prescriptions
benefits plans, implemented Spousal surcharge if you've all seen
it, and also perform the dependent eligibility audit
and there's maybe other stuff that has been done. So these are the major items
that I do want to highlight before we go to the next slides.
Next slide. So again, what's next? Again,
it's important to understand what we work with at this point.
We do have the limitations on the property tax revenue cap, in city
charter and state cap. So not just the city's local
cap, but there's also state cap that we have to work and comply with.
Another limitation is public safety. It is something to
note that police and fire costs make up about 57% of the
general fund and also COVID impact.
So which is the economic uncertainties that we are dealing with at
this point. COVID and of course what happened
in Russian invasions to Ukraine. So that would impact
the oil prices, again, the volatility in the economy.
So on the short terms, it is important for us
to build and preserve fund balance. Again, to be conservative,
continue to leverage ARPA funding, to address revenue losses, continue hiring
control and also look for efficiencies and cost cutting
opportunities, developing new revenue sources. And I
briefly mentioned that in the press conference yesterday.
And again continue working day one to build the fund balance as
we had into fiscal year 23, 24 and 25.
In the long terms, again, continue to look into those
implementing PFM recommendations that are supported by both
mayor and yourself, city Council in
which one of that, as you had seen in the past, is the outcome based
budgeting. So we are in the progress to do that.
And so with that we have an
update on the outcome based budgeting and I would refer to Deputy
Director William Jones.
All right. Thank you, Director. And to Mayor Pro TEM and
Council. Time to switch pace a little bit, talk about something a
little fun, at least it is to me. So this is a project I've been
very close to since this
is a project I've been close to since about 2011 twelve.
We've been making small incremental progress throughout the
years, but now I'm excited that we've actually
launched this project. So last summer we kicked off phase one
of the outcome based budgeting project. So if you can bring up the slides please.
Okay, so in phase one, it was
essentially a discovery phase. So we brought in the consultant to come in and look
at our process, look at our systems, look at our technology,
and do an assessment. And with that,
we had a lot of workshops with the departments. And like I said,
throughout the years we had already been working with the departments, making what
progress we could on what our programs and how do
we start looking at our budget a little differently.
From phase one, we conducted 45 workshops.
We had over 100 plus participants. All 26 departments participated,
and we were able to identify hundreds of programs.
And we also looked at some different vendors on some technology solutions.
So phase one was a very successful phase.
So when you look at what does it mean
to implement it successfully, what do we have to
do? So we focused on three key things the people,
technology and process. So those are some
of the findings and recommendations that we looked at. So when you look at the
people, one of the most important things is to have buy
in at the very top, at the very top level with the mayor.
And we definitely have to buy in from the mayor. One of the first things
he did when he came in the office is signed Executive Order 150,
which pretty much outlined a performance based budget
model that the city would move towards. And we also have buy in from
council. I know Councilman Alcorn has been very involved with it. We had an amendment,
I want to say a couple of years ago that we would start that discovery
phase. So we did complete that.
And then not only at the top level, we have to have
engagement with the employees, the managers, the people
that are actually doing the work. And again, we've been doing that.
So we want to keep that momentum that we've had throughout
the year. So even with this budget, I work with
departments to make sure they are thinking about their budget in terms of programs,
have them start thinking of how they would measure those things. And I'll show
you a really good example later in this presentation.
So people is very important. Also technology.
One of the things I found throughout my time of reviewing
outcome based budget and performance based budget is that technology
was a huge barrier for a lot of cities. I think now is
the perfect time that the technology has advanced so much in the past five years.
A lot of cloud based solutions, a lot of solutions that will allow us
to track performance. And I presented with TTI,
I think last month, along with his department,
that we have found a solution that may work for us.
So the technology, like I said, is a very important part. And we've
made a lot of progress. The industry has made a lot of progress on that
front. And probably one of. The most important thing is the process.
So that's one of the key things we focused on,
making sure because it's a major shift for the city to go from
the incremental based budgeting to looking more at performance and focusing
on outcomes. So process is one of the things we're
going to spend a lot of time on in the second phase.
Next slide please. So what's next? So the
next phase, one of the first things, like I said, is focusing on
the process. So redesign and introduce our budget process,
starting with the strategic plan. So one of the major differences with outcome
based budget is you start with your strategic plan,
what are the outcomes that the citizens expect, what are the priorities
of the city, and then we build from
there. So we build our budget knowing what those goals are so
that you know how to prioritize your budget and build your budget from the ground
up. So in this next phase, it's going to be very important that we developed
our process, document our process, change our budget calendar.
We have to look at what new forms do we need to create. So that's
going to be to me one of the most important process before we even get
to the system, because you don't want to get a system and then you're still
trying to figure out your process. You want to get a system, have your process
in place and transition all that over first. So we're going to focus on process
first and then you see on the second bullet, then we're
going to look at implementing a comprehensive budget solution so that's the
technology and the system that I talked about.
And when you look at bullet point number three, then we integrate
all of those solutions together, the process with the system
and making sure everything works together. And then
on number four, again, as I said, one of the most important things is
people making sure that the employees, the managers, understand their role
in this new budgeting format, understand that we need to
track performance. A lot of departments already do
it, but it doesn't drive decisions. So we're going to need to change that
mentality to make sure that they're tracking performance for
the outcomes that we expect and that we're monitoring those and measuring those.
And then again, redefine the talent, provide staff with the support and
resources that they need to be able to do that. This is not an easy
thing and from what I've seen with other cities, they do have challenges. So we
need to make sure that the staff has the support that they
need to be able to track the goals
and build the budget and have that buy in
from the leadership to know that we're all moving in the same
direction. Okay, so the next slide. So this is
the one I really wanted to focus on to show you some of the work
that we've done. So this is real data that we did with the Hits
department. So it's a prototype, but it's based on real
data. So we took their revolving fund budget,
which is 98.1 million. So what they did, if you
look at the very bottom, you'll see the programs. So we identified about
13 programs within the Hits department. So if you're looking at it,
you can see how much more relevant that the data is here.
When you're looking at the budget, you can see looking at the first one
citywide customer service, three one one program.
People may not know that the Hits involvement with the Three One one program.
And when we look at it from a global perspective, well, you know,
three one one is in Ara as well. And then the goal is
to be able to show how much are we spending on three one one.
Then you start measuring what is the call time, how long does it take
to respond, and then you can start measuring that to see, okay,
are we performing accurately or do we need to
put more money there or do we need to reassess? And then how long
does it take for responses to be responded to
by other departments? But until we have it's difficult to
see in our current budget. But if we have program called Three one One that
crosses other departments and we can see the total cost of what
it is to run a three one one program, then we can make better decisions
on how we fund those programs. So like I said, altogether it's about
13 programs there. And then you go up to the next level.
Now we're going to tie those programs into the priorities
because right now, we don't know how much we're spending on the priorities of the
city. So that'll be one of the big changes. And then you go up to
the next level, and then we tie it to the plan.
Houston, the core strategies, that the citizen survey,
that what they expect. Right now, we can't tell them how much are we spending
on sustaining quality infrastructure. Like I
said, right now we're just looking at Hits. But once we get this
entire thing up and running, then we can provide the citizens
with better data to be able to understand where their dollars are going
and also provide council with better information on how
we can make decisions and fund these things. So like I said, I'm very excited
that we've kicked this project off officially.
Phase two is going to like it's going to be a challenge. So the goal
is we're still aiming for FY 24 with the
hopes of for sure having the process in place. Now, the system
may take a little more time, but like I said, the process is the
most important part. But we're definitely going to get a system, but without
the process, to me, the system can wait, but we're moving forward
with both. So by FY 24,
we'll have some form of outcome based budgeting to present
to you guys. So on the next slide,
and this just shows you kind of how our reporting would look
taking that same data with hits, you can see, you get the program description,
what are the goals of that program, and then you'll see now we're starting to
put measures tying it to those programs. And then
throughout the year, we would have to track, are we hitting those targets?
If not, then what do we need to do? So it's a different
way of looking at your budget, not focusing on how much
do we spend on this department, how much do we spend on that department,
but what are the programs that we're providing to the citizens and how are they
performing. So my hope is that not only do we change,
provide the citizens with better information on how their dollars are being spent,
but also kind of change how council can look at the budget and get away
from the little line items here and there and the department spending
there, and focus on those programs and start paying attention
to what we're measuring.
Okay, I think that's it for that. So before I turn
it over to questions, I do want to take a moment to recognize my
team. I had them put on their Sunday's Best in March over here.
So I'm going to ask them to stand up, team. Stand up,
all of you.
These are the people that work nights and weekends
to get this budget done. And all I had to do is bribe them with
a little food and they put in the work. So to say
I'm proud of them would be a huge understatement.
And I've had the highest number of vacancies I've ever had going into a budget
cycle, so they did triple the workload. And I am extremely
proud of this group here. So thank you guys.
The last 15 years I've been with the city, I think this is the least
amount of teams we have to do the budget.
So I'm very proud. Thank you so much.
Retention. Retention. So we will burn people and they actually
leave. That's what we have.
You guys ready for questions? Yes. All right, you got the easy part over
with. Here comes the tough part. So council member Sally Alcorn will start us off.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. And I did notice a slight uptick in
the food line item for the Finance Department. Now I know why,
but that's money well spent. And thank you guys for a great job. This is
a really huge undertaking and
will thank you for all the attention to outcome based
budgeting. I just think that's going to be key to look at our
programs and services that we provide. It's very difficult to see
that in our current budget structure, and I think that will really help
us to prioritize. So very happy about that. I'll just run through
a few questions really quick. It's my understanding the $160,000,000 of
ARPA funding that's being put in the 23 budget as part
of the first tranche of money, correct? Correct.
Okay. And the next tranche of money, you had a slide
on there that says we must have this. Is it just committed by
2024, end of 2024 and spent then
by 2026, obligated by 24.
Obligated by 24 and spent by end of year 2026.
Yes. Okay. Thank you. On the inflation rate,
you mentioned that a 4.8% number and a
4.28% number 4.28. Okay.
So for purposes of the rev,
Captain, it's 4.28. The 4.8
I misspoke. So I corrected myself. I get the four
and the eight, but it's 4.28%. Okay. So we
operate under the lesser of that inflation rate plus
population, or four and a half percent. So right now we'd
still be under CPI plus population when calculating that. Okay,
thank you. And on the
senior exemption, the 160,000 that the mayor announced would
be going to 260,000. I believe that's not an assumption
in the plan for this year. When would that kick in
or have an effect? Right. So the
senior tax exemptions and disabled will be in effect
starting July 1.
So that is not going to be impacting the budget because the budget is
just based on the revenues. So that would be impacting
the citizens when we actually look at the tax rates.
Right. So they would have some savings. Got it. So that
doesn't have any correct. Okay. In here. And then on
the Hmeps legacy contribution, can you explain
that again? I think you briefly touched on there were two categories on
your assumptions for pensions. One was the legacy and
one was just a rate. Can you?
Yeah. So remember in that pension reform,
one of the item that came out of
that Senate bill on the municipal pensions,
it's actually two portions. So there is a legacy amount which
is based on a dollar agreement on the dollars payment for out years.
Okay. And also a percent rate.
Yeah, now I remember. Right. But not going to fire in pension is
just based on the corridor midpoint. Thank you.
Council member Abby Cayman.
Sorry we're having to share Mikes. Director,
thank you for your presentation to the entire team concerned
about but for ARPA, where we would be in
the projections and the gaps that you're showing in some of
those slides, it's extremely concerning. Do we know and
you may have already said this, but just for the public,
how many projected dollars were not captured due to the
revenue limitations in the cap that are
currently in place?
Thank you for bringing that up on slide 15.
So that is the impact on the revenue cap.
So the impact for fiscal year 23,
if we don't have a cap, it would have been about 282,000,000 that
we could have used to serve the
city. So that is one of the
items in your statements. So the other one is, if not
for ARPA, then essentially you would have about $160,000,000 gap
to close, which could impact public safety. And it was
also striking on page 17 that since fiscal
year 2015, the full impact of the property tax cap
has been 1.818 excuse me, billion dollars.
So thank you for providing that.
You started to emphasize it, but with the fund balance,
how important is that to
preserve, especially with the revenue losses
that we've experienced during the Pandemic?
Very. Thank you for bringing that up. Very. Because if you remember,
what we have from ARPA is essentially to replenish the
revenue we lost. So it's not something
that now that we have the money, then this is the money that we spent
today. But those are enough to recover
the revenue losses we have. And again, ARPA is going to be ending
in December 31, 2024. And so that
money is not going to be available. So the hope is that the economy would
be picking up back again at that point. So it is very
important for us to preserve the sun balance at this point. We'll put you back
in queue. Thank you, Council Member Plumber and then Council Member Martin,
thank you so much for all the work that everyone has done. I know this
is tough. So, a couple
of questions. I know we talked about the impact
of the cap, the revenue cap. Is that money completely
gone or is that money injected to the
city in other ways, through management districts, to other avenues,
or is that just not it's not.
So remember when
we hit the revenue, the property tax revenue cap back in
fiscal year 15, we actually have to set our
general fund budget at the cap, which translate
when you actually go through the truth and taxations and voting
for the tax rate to meet that revenue cap,
we would have to adjust our tax rates. So it's
lost because essentially we have to reduce the tax rate to be at
the revenue cap. Okay, and then
the other two more questions. I really
appreciate how you listed in more detail what we did in terms
of implementing the PFM report. Do you have an idea
and I know this is totally an approximation, and maybe you don't even know,
but do you have an idea what that number collectively would look like
dollar wise? Dollar wise? No, we don't.
Because it has to ask for individual calculations with the
no, we don't. I'm just curious to see we spent so much money on that
report. I would just be curious to see what savings, how we
benefited from making those adjustments. Well, you could see
already with the pension reform yeah, no,
we have that. With the OPEC reform, you get the impact on what
the potential reductions in unfunded liabilities
in there. Health benefits. I think that would reduce
our health benefits and I think that was presented earlier as well.
That would reduce our cost this year because of the health benefits.
I definitely see the benefit. I just would love to know what the number was
collectively. Okay, we'll put you back in queue. Okay,
so I'm going to go to slide 29.
Okay, what's next,
addressing the gap? The reason why I'm bringing this up is three of us sitting
around here are leaving. This is our second to last budget, and you're going to
be in charge of the next couple of budgets. And while we have
a really good picture this year, we have an abysmal picture after
we leave. And I'm going to point that out short term,
building up fund balance. Yeah, we're going to continue to do that.
You do that by all these initiatives hiring control, creating efficiencies,
cost cutting opportunity. That means increasing revenue sources.
That's taxes and fees, continuing one day to build fund balance.
So the really number one thing is build fund balance. How do you do that?
So I'm going to go to page 26,
and there was a question that was asked of me last week to prepare
for this. And the person said, dave, how much of our retirement
pay, our defined benefit pay that we pay employees, is included
in OPEB other post employment benefits? Does anybody
know the answer to that?
Zero. OPEB has nothing to
do with retirement pay. It has everything to do mainly with health
care, disability and things of that nature. And the vernacular
and the the verbiage around here is always around OPEB.
OPEB has nothing to do with our big bugaboo, that's retirement pay.
And if you look at slide 26, correct me if
I'm wrong, the retirement pay that we're going to pay this year
in this budget is $436,000,000. Is that
correct,
yes or no? No. The 436 is the debt
payment. Where is the retirement
pay that we're obligated to pay for retirees in fiscal year 2023?
Because I looked through this big book and all I can find is
debt and pay as you go. Is it in here?
It should be in the health benefits, yeah. Okay.
I'm looking for a number because I looked through it and I couldn't find it.
So it's a big number. It's a big number. I think it's
not as big as police, not as big as fire. That's one and two.
But I think it's the third largest expenditure that we will have to pay.
Correct me if I'm wrong. Out of the general fund,
we do have this breakdown on the retirees classified in
civilians, so we can provide it to you. What is
the number? I want a number to everyone to hear because it's
a big number that we never talk about. Oh, yeah,
it's all there. I know all I have in here is the general fund,
but of course, you're looking at the citywide expenditures. Okay. It's a big
number, right? The general fund is at least 60. And then
when we go to slide 21, we talk about pension
reform. Well, my opinion a
lot of that is working fantastic,
especially rate of return because we always guaranteed
a rate of return. In the last couple of years,
a monkey could have received got you a high rate of return.
Anyone could have done that. In this fiscal year, I think
it's going to be a negative rate of return. So the corridor is
going to have to be looked at because that corridor is going to kick
in, which is a softening, a blending of a five year analysis.
Correct. So I think while your projections
I disagree with two of your projections. Number one, sales tax revenue
at zero. I went to the grocery store last night because I have family
coming in this weekend, and I didn't buy any meat or any chicken or any
pork or anything. I bought household items,
toilet paper, things of that nature. It was $462. And it's
my wife and I, so I don't go to the grocery store that often.
But sales tax are going to be a component of that. I think
sales tax revenue is going to continue as we've seen, continue to
increase. And to classify it as zero, I think
isn't going to be accurate. The second part is, I think,
the liability on the pension side, while we've done a good job of moving
it from 8.2 to 1.5, I think we're going
to have a little bit of a kick up because of guaranteed rate of the
return, softening the market, the interest rates that we're seeing,
et cetera. So my ultimate question is that
how do we looking at your slot of long term things to
do? It has a big category up there of the PFM
recommendations. So there's
only one thing you can do, one thing only,
and to move employees from defined contribution
benefit to defined contribution, that's it
hard thing to do. We made an obligation to our
employees, dave Martin's opinion, and we live up to that obligation.
So if you started work yesterday, you're going to receive a divine benefit plan.
But somewhere down the road you got to begin a defined contribution
plan to get rid of this $463,000,000
of growing liability that comes out of the general fund
year in and year out. Until you do that,
we will never pass a structurally balanced budget.
The mayor used the term yesterday. Well, it's pretty close to
being structurally balanced, and it's a hard thing to do.
It's in government because of the defined benefit
plan that we have. So unless you attack that
and when I leave, I want to leave this financial
position of the city better than I came in with.
And I would invite a discussion
on the movement of new employees, let's say
January 1, 2023,
for them to move to a different benefit plan like we've
done. I think in four different instances. We have four different retirement plans.
A fifth one out there has to be defined contribution,
because if you don't do that, you will continue to build your liability
year after year after year, and you will never,
ever get out of it. Do you disagree or
agree with those statements?
That is one of the way to reduce is, yes, defined contributions.
But I know there's a lot of factors to
play in. And again, you are the decisions maker.
But yes, it's one of the way. Yeah, I mean,
it's a tough discussion to have because people say,
well, pay is different. And I think we've done an okay job of
pay. Okay job. That's my opinion. I looked at it
as it compares to corporate. We're losing a lot of good people to
corporate. So we probably have to do something to the general
pay of employees.
I know I haven't heard of the ding. I'm probably talking too long, but when
I talk to young college graduates let
me finish this. When I talk to young college graduates and ask them,
when you go to work, what are you looking for? They never once mentioned I'm
looking for in 40 years what my defined
contribution benefit plan is going to look like. They want pay,
they want family time, which we help, which we did with
the parental leave. They want vacation.
They want really cost of really ease
of living and things that make their life, family life, balance a lot better.
I'll come back to summarize that. I'll go now to council Member
Abby Cayman.
Thank you. I'm going to
divert away from this current topic, but I
did want to ask one thing. As we're mentioning retirement,
assisting those who may need assistance, things of that nature,
how much are our seniors and disabled homeowners
getting with the proposed increase in the homestead exemption
or how much are they going to be saving?
So we run some calculations on that. Again, this is going
to be a proposal that the mayor is going to bring forward separately to the
council to increase the senior and disabled tax
exemptions from 160,000 to 260,000.
So we look at an average homes
of 300,000, for example. When we look at that.
Now, keep in mind, there is also a standard
homestead exemption, which is 20% of the values, right?
So when you look at the average home of 300,000,
you're looking at about saving. This is approximate about $440
per annual, about $440
that they can save.
And again, this is based on our current tax rate. Thank you.
Thank you.
Council member. Leticia plumber.
Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you. And just to piggyback a little bit on the mayor protem, I do
appreciate and we had a discussion in one of the budget meetings about your bringing
forth some recommendations. Short term and long term,
they're pretty broad, and we're going to have to be more specific about
them. We're a
people business. And I think we have made some strides in health benefits.
Even the $75 surcharge for spouses,
that made an impact. People left and went to
a spouse, went to their own insurance. I think that made it being a
people business. You can't get at the structural imbalances without things
like pension and health benefits and things and things,
salaries that impact people. So they are tough discussions,
Mayor Protem, but you're right on the money. I mean, those are the kinds of
things that will bring us into structural balance. One point,
and I forgot to mention council member David Robinson, council Member Carolyn Evans
Chabaz and Council Member Robert Gallegos has
joined us a long time ago. Got you
twice, so you deserve to be gotten twice. So there
are no other comments or questions from council members.
You just popped in. Tiffany d thomas.
Sorry, quick question. This is for Mr. Will. Can you go back and clarify
the transition for the It? You talked about a
process, phase two, and then the system implementation.
Can you give the timeline for that? Again, I didn't catch that.
Let me go back. So the process is what we're
working on now. So what I'm waiting for is to map out
how long is it going to take to change the process, and then I can
find out how long it's going to take for us to get a system in
place. So I don't know the timeline exactly for the system, but I will
know probably by next month or so. Yes, sir.
Is that it, TIFF? Yes,
thank you. So my last comments,
I think it's something we need to study. Is it something we need to implement
on a certain time frame? That's for council to decide and to
debate. But I think it's something that we really need to look at. And can
you do a hodgepodge of different plans? What are the options that are
available to reduce the long term liability? Because we
have balanced this budget by a number of measures. Thank God for ARPA
funds, previous land sales, and divestitures of property.
That's how we've always balanced the budget to a certain
degree. So one of the things that the mayor said yesterday in his press conference,
which is totally accurate, when the credit agencies look at
us, moody's, Standard and Poors, Fitch, even Dun and Brad Street,
they look at the viability, long term viability of the city,
and they say, well, as he said yesterday, you're restricted by
three things. Revenue cap. Well, that's not going away unless the state
changes pension reform, moving from
8.2 billion of liability to 1.5 billion
a plus. Excellent idea. Excellent concept.
That works. OPEB liability,
OPEB trust fund or creation? As Council Member Alcorn mentioned,
we've done a few things on the health benefit side for retirees to
make that more fiscally prudent for the city.
The next iteration of that is how do you handle the lingering
defined benefit payment that some
folks are retiring in their drawn retirement pay in
their we've done a really good job of
looking at drop and doing something with that. But I would
recommend that this body study that and
really look hard at maybe coming up with some
type of a plan not for existing employees,
but for employees that aren't in this building today. Because I
believe when you make a commitment to employees, you live up to it.
And if you have that on the paper today, you should be
responsible for that till the day that that person leaves and retires
and does other things. But I still am convinced that the long
term fiscally prudent thing, according to our
consultants that we engaged a couple of years ago, was looking at that.
We do have five public
speakers for the five year forecast. We'll start off
with Ms. Sarah Blanding.
Saba blanding star
six to unmute Ms. Blanding. Welcome again.
You're an active participator in these. Thank you.
Saba Blanding. Star six to unmute.
Mute. And if not, we will come back to you.
We can see you, but we can't hear you. Star six,
we have you now.
Star six again,
speak. I'm unmuted. Can you hear me okay?
Yes. Okay. Wonderful. Apologies for
that delay. I had a few questions for you all.
The first is what is the impact of the various collective
bargaining agreements on this forecast? I'd love to hear you all
discuss if you have some time today and kind
of along with that, what information do you have about the potential
financial impact of pay parity for firefighters if that
ends up having to be implemented? I noticed there was a 6% increase
for firefighters, but I wasn't 100% sure how that
would impact the budget.
And yeah, I guess I'll throw in one more question
if I have time. Many council
members in the mayor have mentioned increasing the size of HPD is a
priority. There's five additional cadet classes that are
proposed. What are the long term budget implications
of increasing the classified headcount for HPD, especially considering
the passage of House Bill 1900 last summer?
So I'll leave the rest of my time to hear back
from you all. Appreciate it.
Write those down. First question was collective bargaining process. I got
the first. How was it working? So, on slide 18, we do show
the employee compensation impact in the budget, which is about 44.6
million, and that includes all three
employee groups. But it also factors in attrition
and things like that. So it's about 44.6
million in this budget. But that is for Aldo. That's municipal
policing fires. So if
you ask for a 6% fire specific,
I don't have it on the slides, but I can get back to you
on that and we will post all the answers to SharePoint.
Correct, correct.
Posting the SharePoint. The other question was police
cadets related to budget? If I read the numbers right,
I. Think the number of FTEs, the headcount in Houston Police
Department decreased from by 4%
last year. Fiscal year 22 includes six
cadet classes, and then in this fiscal year, it includes
five cadet classes. Overall number of police department employees
decreased by 4% last fiscal year to
this fiscal year, according to your projection.
Go ahead. I was going to say just retirement on our question,
it's not five additional classes, it's five if
six was in the base. So we actually reduced to five. So it's
not a growth in classes. So in terms of the
budget for that cost, it actually was a little lower for the cadet
classes. For police going into 23. They're not additional.
And according to Chief Finner, it was five
classes at like 55 cadets. It's going to be five classes at
70 plus cadets. So we'll have what's,
equivalent to a six class built into the five class process?
Correct. Okay, next speaker, Mr.
Jason Oliver. Star six,
please.
Good afternoon, everyone.
So I want to follow up because I heard Saba ask about
the impact of pay parity and what might be the potential impact of
that, not the specific raise, the six six six that
was implemented. So I want to follow up on that.
Do you all have that information?
Go ahead. I was going to say, so that would have to be a new
analysis. When we looked way back,
2018 or 19, we were looking at
the pay parity analysis. So much has changed since then.
So, no, we don't have that number right now.
Yeah. This budget presentation is purely
focused on what is in the fiscal year 23 operating
budget. In this fiscal year 23 budget, we include
a 6% pay raises for the firefighters.
That would significantly, probably change and increase our
liabilities, though, right? We get much closer
and probably move beyond the pessimistic. Is that the case?
I'm sorry, say that again. We'd probably end up
moving much closer to or perhaps beyond the pessimistic
if the decision ends up going toward the firefighters.
Is that the case? So if there is any cases
and increased expenses that happen during the fiscal year,
then yes, it will be something that we will have to address at that
point. Okay.
And the personnel challenges that you all mentioned for finance,
right. Like you talked about a high number of Vacancies. That seems to be
an issue across the city's departments. Do you see a need
for more competitive pay in the city? And if so, is that factored
into your projections?
Competitive pay? Yeah. No, I mean, I think it's a combination of things
that you're seeing across this in the city is what we're seeing throughout the
United States with the great resignation. So it's a combination
of things. And I do believe the city is starting
to move in the right direction with the parental leave to be able
to retain employees. Of course, pay.
We're always looking at studying certain positions to see if
we're paying appropriately. Like I know we put a lot of attention in legal
for the attorneys because that's where we're losing a lot of attorneys
because of pay. So we are doing those things. So I'm hoping
that with these things we're doing we'll start to be able to
retain more employees. But it's across the nation, not just the city,
that's facing this problem. And if I could add, keep in mind as well human
resource departments also conducted those market
studies right. Which is based on the financial policies every three
years. Thank you. Okay. And my last
question to increase the fund balance is a
reduction in spending on classified officers a viable
strategy to ensure fiscal sustainability since they're one of
our largest general fund liabilities. In theory,
the fund balance will be increased either from the increased revenues or
reduction in expenditures. It's just based on what we
dealt with, revenues and expenditures. Any increase in the fund balance,
it's just a combination of both.
Okay, thank you. Thank you. And I made a mistake.
SharePoint is only available to council members and staff, but if
you have questions and you'd like us to answer them, email us at
District E at houst gov and we will work
you to get the questions answered. Once again.
District e at Houst gov.
Mr. Arisbrown.
Star six, please.
Hi, this is Aris Brown. I'm sorry. Go ahead.
No worries. Hi, I have a couple of questions. One of
the questions I was thinking about one
of the sections within the general fund revenue section it
was focused on increasing the budget by funds from Park
Houston and that I believe relies on cars and parking
costs even though Houston has been slowly but surely implementing more
bike routes and hopefully more reliable public transit. So one
of my questions was about the priorities of the city in
the coming years. Is there still going to be a reliance upon a car centric
city and relying upon the revenues that come from cars? And I'm curious
about how that aligns with the goals to be bike
routes and walkability and that sort
of progressive idea, especially as we see uncertainty in
the oil industry. So that was one of my questions. Another one
of my questions was about the outcome based budget.
We've had conversations about this with past budget
conversations, workshops, et cetera, in which community
members have expressed their concerns and wanted to offer ideas
about how to implement the needs of their
community. So I'm curious about they're in the basis of implementing
outcome based budget, factor in community engagement and
an analysis of ethics and community ethics.
I did not get the first one but I think
I follow your second questions on the outcome based
budgeting to engage the public.
Right now, the outcome based budgeting is an internal process
so that we can provide the information relevant
to the Council for decisions
which is based on the current programs that is
in the departments at this point.
I think that's all I can add. Yeah, I would just add that the
Plan Houston really is kind of driving from the community engagement.
So if planning does another update to
the Plan Houston or all of that will drive some of
the community involvement.
Yeah, no, thank you to rephrase. I guess my
first question, I'm looking at the funding.
I think there's a little
footnote that says that the
increase primarily in transfer from Park Houston Fund
on page ten, on page
ten of the fiscal year 2023 general fund revenue,
including other resources, there's the sub note seven that
says that there's an increase primarily in transfer from Park East and Fund,
which means parking. I'm curious about how that aligns
with being a less car centric city and having more people
driving, having people more like biking and walking and public transport,
transit. I'm curious about how those two align and whether or not they do align.
Is there still a goal to be a less car centric city or
are we still going to rely for the next couple of years on
parking costs and those sorts of things, even with the uncertainty
in the oil industry? I think I follow I know it's a little bit mumbling,
but I think I follow the jess of your question.
So you're going back to slide ten where we have an increased
revenues transfer from the Park Houston Fund.
Correct. So based on the ordinance
created for the Park Houston Fund, and that is a
special fund, so essentially any excess
fund over, I believe it's 2 million is to be transferred to the general
fund. So in the last year, the last two years,
of course with the stay at home and the pandemic,
there is no such revenues generated in that special fund.
So now that it start picking up, then that fund has been
generating revenues. In that sense, the ordinance can be picking up
back again where any excess of a 2 million will
be transferred to the general fund. So this is not impacting
the current operations of the special fund itself. This is just
a financial that is aligned to the ordinance created
for that fund. Thank you,
Ms. Brown. Next speaker is Mr. Christopher Rivera.
Christopher Rivera, star six.
Hello? Can you hear me? Yes, we can. Go ahead.
Great. Thank you everyone. I'm just going to give a little
context for my question.
This fiscal year, the Housing and Community Department will only receive
0.1% of what the Houston Police Department is expected
to receive in funding. Examining the overall budget, the housing department will
only receive 0.1% from the $2.74 billion
general budget. As the city cuts funding for housing,
rent is continuously increasing. Local reports say rent
has gone up 23% in Houston, but experts say they will not come down.
The rent increase is only making it harder for Houstonians to stay safe and
sheltered. Just last week, there was 783
Evictions filed in Houston, and since March 2020,
there has been over 85 Evictions filed.
Houstonians are struggling to keep themselves safe because they are losing the ability to pay
their homes or apartments. The city needs to reimagine public safety and
consider housing programs as a solution to public safety issues.
Now, my question is, in the next five years,
how will the city of Houston address our growing public safety need for affordable
permanent housing programs when it continues to deplete public
safety services like housing only into
increased services that criminalize communities like the police budget.
So I know on housing departments,
the large revenue source they have is through
the grants. A large of their operations is grant funded.
I think you mentioned about public safety in that
area. I understand that police departments do work hand in hand
with housing departments and any other departments when it comes to public
safety to support those operations as well.
You probably will get more details from housing departments when we do have those
specific budget workshop. But again, this is a general fund
and they do have a small portions in the general fund because
they are largely funded out of grants. So here's my
follow up. How will we become self sustainable?
And just in case we lose those federal grants,
it will be something that we have to adjust. And I think that's, like I
said, it's one of those importance to preserve fund
balance because those needs will arise. And I think that's why we
have those set aside,
fund balance to prepare us going forward.
Thank you. Mr. Rivera, I think that's an outstanding question.
We talked about that at council this morning. Affordable housing.
I'm not sure if there is such a thing as affordable housing. What I'm seeing
in the marketplace, every time you turn around, interest rates are going
up and affordable housing costs are going through the roof
with the cost of material. So you're exactly right.
That is going to be a challenge for us in this world that we live
in, is how we define affordable housing, how do we deal with it? And I
know that the Housing Committee, in the hands of Tiffany Thomas, is doing
a great job with that and will continue to do a great job with that.
But that is a tough question to answer for all of
us. I know it is for me.
Thank you. Last but not least, mr. Doug Smith.
Doug, I hope you're feeling better.
I felt better for days, but I'm still testing negative,
positive, so that's why I'm not there today. But thank you for asking.
Stay away. Yeah, I will.
That's what Jessica said too. And then I intend to hopefully
by next Monday I'll be testing negative. But in
any case, a couple of questions. First of all, do I understand correctly
that the first tranche of the ARPA funds
around $300 million, about half was used last
year and half was used this year. And you have not taken the
other 300 million into consideration. When you did
your proposed what was the proposed budget gap? I think I understood you
to say that. And then I wanted to address you talked
about how we continue to
address the gap and you say continue hiring control.
And yet when I look at the General Fund budget,
between 2021 and the projected 2023,
there's an addition of 766, full time equivalents.
And in addition to that, obviously there's
the huge one, huge large increases in pay that you're going
to have to deal with over the next three years as the previous
ones, the agreements come in. And finally,
I think let me check, I think that's it
on page 76, 26 of your presentation,
under your projections for the police and the firefighters,
you have a low for the police of 27, three to 30,
212, and you project them at nearly the full
high amount. And for the fire department,
you project them at the very lowest amount. And I'm curious
how you decided to differentiate that.
And then finally, on the outcome based budget,
on page 33, you have different categories
that need to be met. Do you have timelines for when you expect to
have those categories done?
And that's it.
I think the first question was related to FTEs. He said
there's an increase of FTEs of I think it was 700 and
some odd. Yes,
766.
2nd question was a counterpart
of that with pay, increase in pay, 6% for fire,
4% for police. Yes,
municipal. So how do you afford increasing FTEs
and increasing pay within the confines of the general budget? I think that was
his question. Yeah, exactly. And as
it relates to your goal to address the gap, to continue
hiring control, it makes it very difficult to do that with
those figures I'm trying to follow. When you say
increase in FTEs, are you looking at the citywide FTEs from
a specific fiscal year?
No, just the general fund. On the General Fund FTEs
on page twelve. Page twelve,
slide twelve. I'm looking
at page twelve. Hang on table
five at the very bottom, because if I'm looking at
page seven, which is General Fund specific,
I'm showing a reduction from fiscal year 22
to 23, from 13 seven
to 13 five. I just want to
make sure we are on the same page.
Excuse me. It was 2021, was the base year
between 2021 and projected 2023,
there's an increase of 766 when
you add both the regular plus the
overtime FTEs. Okay, keep in mind in fiscal year, and I think
we have that in the footnote, fiscal year 20 and fiscal year 21,
it shows a lower FTEs because of the redeployment that
are funded out of CRF.
So that FTEs in 21 and 20 and 2020
were kind of skewed because of some of those are funded
out of CRF. And not out of the general fund.
What is CRF again? Okay, and I think you
also asked about the assumptions on the fire pension back in
page 26, correct?
Yes. Okay, so the reason why on fire
pension and police pension, we have the low and the high.
Again, this is on the pension city contributions, which is again
governed by the pension reform. Right now,
for the fire pensions, they are below the
minimum corridor. So when you fall below the minimum corridor,
the city contributions will be based on the minimum point, not the midpoint.
Okay. And that's why we put a range, because that can change in the
next five years.
Okay. Question. What is CRF? You referred to CRF.
What is that? CRF.
CRF. That is the Coronavirus Relief Fund. That is based on the
Care. Okay. That's the cares act.
Okay, fine. Correct. And I guess finally,
do you have time limits or can you assign timelines
to your outcome based budget? Page 33
of the various steps that have to take place before this happens.
So, first step will be the process.
So I do anticipate by December
of next year we will have the process in place.
What I don't know is that the system will be ready by then, but the
goal is for FY 24 budget, hopefully by December, at least
we have the outcome based budgeting process in place so that we
can follow the process. Thanks, Mr.
Smith. Okay, thank you.
Before we move on to Houston Fire Department, are there any other questions
or comments from council members? We have no other
public speakers that have signed up to speak in person,
so I will ask again, is there any comments or
questions from council members before we dismiss the great city of
Houston finance team?
Okay,